hey folks Caroline here i'm joined today
by karl Roloffs design director at zou
joy and we're here to actually today to
talk about a game that I'm really
excited about cuz it's a revival of an
adventure game that I have very very
fond memories of shadowgate why don't
you talk a little bit about like the
kind of history of shadowgate and what
it means to be bringing it back today
great great pleasure to be here so um
this was shadowgate was a game that was
designed back in the 80s with Dave Marsh
myself I've known Dave virtually my
whole life and we've worked together on
and off through our careers and we've
always wanted to bring shadowgate back
i'm chad i gave a first came out in the
mac in the old black-and-white mode and
then it went on to the various PC clones
and Ataris and Commodores and everything
else and I just been ported over and
over and over again and the opportunity
came a couple years ago when Double Fine
did their Kickstarter and they were so
successful we just said to each other
well why not why not you shadowgate so
that kind of prompted us to revisit this
and get shadowgate underway again well
cool why don't you start it up and let's
take a look at at the new reimagine
shadowgate there's there's three
difficulties there is an apprentice mode
the journeyman mode in the master mode
we have some tutorials which we never
had in shadowgate so hopefully that will
help people just get into the game if
you remember from the mac version way
back when you would just be dumped in
front of a castle with a picture of a
castle and here we just try to give you
some reason for you being there and how
you got there so this this was an
opportunity with this reimagining for us
to flesh out more the story so
so this uh you know all this stuff just
kind of introduces lakme r as a
character in the game which was in the
original game and you as a character as
well the original game I don't think we
never had a name for the original a
character we gave him the name
cheerleader on and this is just the
opportunity to just get into character
and just understand kind of what's going
on who you are so and you were also
introducing you to the big baddie in the
game again we just dumped you in the
game so you had no idea who this guy was
and this just gives you an idea that
there's something going on with this guy
so now we dump you into the game yeah a
lot more like world-building happening
here than in the original ok so this is
definitely reminiscent of my memory of
like the very beginning of classic
shadowgate on the mac in front of this
this door right right so it's a you know
it's it's a graphic adventure so it is
an adventure game so text is important
and you can also interact with every
object that that we allow you to so you
can click on things and do various
commands like look which will give you
some texts kind of give you an idea what
you might be able to do with things you
can try to take things or do crazy
things so I'm trying to open up that and
you can't do that let me let me try the
door here so no that's locked and it
looks like there's something back there
let me try to take that and this guy
starts talking there so I can't really
take the key until right and and the
skull is important part of the game this
is York so he introduces himself to you
he's kind of this this unknown character
you really really don't know who he is
but he's a basically a sidekick who
helps you through the game
he's our hint system he also offers
various banter throughout the game let's
do something here so I could go and use
this Dirk on things but if you notice i
click use dirk and now i got click it
the Dirk use it on what so I can not use
it on myself I get a comment after pause
you rethink your suicidal thought we
want to give you the benefit of doubt if
you do it on accident but i'm showing
you this because we we introduced this
feature called quick use so what i can
do is i can bind a key to a to an object
and in this case thing when you hit
control one now the dirk is is a bound
to one so at any time if I hit one it's
a used Dirk on something so I can use it
on myself again you know and it's still
saying you're really sure you want to do
that well I don't want to do that
because I don't want to kill myself
right away here so I'm going to use the
dark on this thing right here because
there's a hell so we can take the helm
and I can kind of look at it I notice
it's not here but my outfit tab is
glowing this is where I put it it's an
outfit because I can wear it so now we
put the helm on him so if you remember
from the mac eyes yeah the eyes going
back and forth yes i did was text so
this gives us the chance to have some
fun and have add some drama you know to
the game by adding some great effects so
um just a couple other things with the
command stuff so you know i can use
myself on things but i can also use i
know so another quick thing is i can use
double click and that's you met actually
that's totally from the mac so you know
and that's definitely effective
something else you can do you can lock a
command so now i can just go and i can
look at things i looked at the torch
there's the door oh that was the key
that I just must have opened up you know
and here's a hatch so I can look at a
bunch of things going to get an idea
what's in the room and I can look back
at
things that I've done in examined okay
so a lot of that's familiar stuff it's
just kind of given to you in a different
and it just looks different so i canna t
take a torch but let's just how about we
leave the room so double click double
click to go through and this is the
infamous trap room you know one you know
a couple things i really wanted to try
to do was make sure that we have enough
clues in the game you know you get room
text here that talks about a musty
breeze coming from behind the altar hmm
maybe there's something to that right
and then also note you know the layout
of the room here people may not realize
that they can go down over here and you
can I want to take you to a room that
you probably remember well from the mac
days and everybody else may be
remembering also from any s is the I'll
get there in a second let's talk about a
couple things in this room so there's
lots of things so this will be different
to you but it's a similar room from the
original you just may not know it yet
I've got this thing over here double
click on that it's something made of ice
and cold it's kind of let's take it yeah
nope I can't take it so it must be
something else other things let's do
this so I did my torch and that's at two
so now my lit torch so i can i can burn
anything I want and what I'm going to do
is I'm going to there's something up
there I'm going to burn that
that's a creature up there right looks
kind of scary let me show you another
feature full that'll be different we
have a map and you know this maps out
every room you've been in and when I
examined the spider notice how it came
there so there are various things you
can examine that will actually appear on
your map and those are there to kind of
give you hints that may help you on
later puzzles or they may not but
they're interesting things in the castle
so this may be just a reminder there's a
spider there and that may help you later
in the game or may not so now here's the
infamous dragon room so this should be
very familiar to people know the game
and if not then you know it's it's it's
a cool fun thing anyway so I kind of
know what to do here so I'm immediately
going to equip this iron shield and if
you remember from the vert you know we
had this long line of flame that came
out at you and if you had the shield
then you were good to go and this is one
that's kind of similar to all the
original games so I'm going to lock like
I want a lot to take I'm going to take a
bunch of things because there's good
things in here
so the shields holding up nicely let's
take this thing cuz it looks good
you see that they look kind of
interesting didn't it let's go look at
that there's a guy with glasses huh so
so I pried out the dirt but I'm in this
room with this dragon so he's still
responding every turn and still trying
to kill me so even though I'm doing
something else you know it's it's you
know he's continuing and the shield is
beginning to melt home so the shield is
completely destroyed now so but you know
I I don't I don't get it so I'm going to
just take off my helm i john Lennon
glasses on me over there so you can see
that so I took it off and he's still
gonna blow fire on me so you know she
death is death is a frequent part of the
shadow gate experience as I recall yes
we actually relish you know killing the
player yeah in most any way we can so so
this is the mirror room you may remember
this I do it probably has more mirrors
yeah then then you remember so I can you
know there's some interesting stuff
going on here because things are
enchanted that one is in so okay that's
kind of interesting York just makes some
you know interesting equipped now and
then but really what I want to do in
this room is show you something I've
already quick bound for quick use my
hammer and I'm gonna
oh no oh oh you've unlike hidden death
mode I didn't expect that ok so we've
we've added special deaths to shadowgate
stuff you can find that you don't have
to do but I just fun to fine and we'll
give you achievements for stuff like
this so I get encourages you to just
like experiment with the environment and
try just try different things like poke
and poke and prod things and see what
happens yeah you know I mean it's it's
it's it's not a winning strategy just
try everything on anything but it's fun
sometimes because you get weird
responses funny stuff like this huh now
that's pretty that's pretty great those
that may remember the NES game oh yeah
the music was very memorable from the
NES game yes yes so that's what we added
here let me show you so you can play the
game in in retro mode and i want to show
you this particular room just because it
looks fun how were replicating the 8-bit
field oh yeah with the flame there and
this people rules will recognize the
quill so this is a mode that working on
where we're still adding a couple things
so that'll be a surprise for players but
at any time I can sit there and if I
really wish to hear the music I can turn
off the graphics but actually I'm going
to go back and turn that on
and we're going to so we got the rickety
bridge here on a primer turkey bridge it
probably never moved like this so that's
not a good thing to go on a rickety
bridge you need some help some way and
then oh that's great that's great that's
classic image right there so that's you
know that's that gives you a taste of
everything that we can add it here yeah
and you know we're were were finishing
beta and we should be releasing some you
know sometime in August okay and on what
how will people be able to access the
game and what platforms okay so we are
releasing on steam first the pc and mac
versions of this game and the mac won't
be black and white so just to just just
if you're wondering and then after that
we're going to go to the tablets we're
going to do android tablets and the
ipads and then after that who knows
where we're going to go well crawl thank
you so much for coming in today and
giving us a look at shadowgate it has
been my pleasure thank you for having me